Top 3 richest men in Ghana.
Can you predict the last one?
No. 3, John Muhammad,
with estimated net worth of $900 million.
John Muhammad is the third on the list of
the top 10 richest men in Ghana.
He once served as the president of Ghana in 2012,
taking over from the deceased President Otta Mills.
Under Muhammad's leadership,
Ghana experienced consistent economic growth
with efforts to strengthen various sectors,
including agriculture and industry.
Number two, Doctor Kwamei Adokufour
with estimated net worth of $1.2 billion.
He is a Ghanaian politician and physician
who held numerous political offices.
While in active service,
he became the minister for defence,
appointed by President John Kufour,
who is his brother.
Before revealing the last one,
please follow this account. Number one,
Ernesto Terraconi
with estimated net worth of $1.3 billion.
F you've asked the question,
who is the richest man in Ghana,
here's is your answer.
As of today,
Ernesto Terraconi is currently the richest man in Ghana
with a net worth of $1.3 billion.
More than 400 Ghanaians
and foreigners are employed by his multiple firms today.